quand une ferme maraîchère décide de
diversifier ses cultures
ça signifie parfois aller lorgner dans
des jardins à l'étranger pour dénicher
des fruits ou des légumes exotiques par
l'histoire qui suit des arbres fruitiers
japonais prennent racine à laval et on
s'arrache leur production
[Musique]
au japon le citronnier dans ses fruits
tard en automne celui là est un you do
cultivées en occident depuis une dizaine
d'années et maintenant à laval au québec
les ou en fait c'est un mélange des
citrons donc de citron jaune comme on
connaît mais ils coûtent beaucoup plus
le jasmin et très poivrée aussi et son
air c'est très très très très parfumée
[Musique]
la ferme richard vaillancourt et son
kiosque sont bien connus à laval c'est
au tour de vis qui de reprendre
l'entreprise familiale
on y apportant un peu d'exotisme elle
possède une centaine de yushu j'avais
besoin d'ajouter mon petit grain de sel
personnel faisait vraiment ma partenaire
c'est un projet lourd horaires continue
à avancer dans la reprise a fait le
doudou est un drôle de citron il a très
peu de jus et beaucoup de pépins
sa peau est très poreuse aussi s'il fait
en sorte que sa forme c'est quand même
différent que citron qu'on connaît en
épicerie par exemple toute sa valeur et
dont les corps ce qui donne aux est
unique
ça sent bon ça sent vraiment il ya des
notes de jasmin de poids ou l'acidulé
s'assembler fleurs ça sent très floral
dont la soeur de laval pousse aussi
quelques spécimens comme la ligne kfir
aux fruits verts connu en cuisine
thaïlandaise le cas la mort d'un qui
ressemble à une petite orange qu'on
trouve aux philippines et le soudage et
qui en dehors du japon est rarissime
c'est moins réussie avec le film the
line le citron caviar il aurait eu
besoin de toute la chaleur de
l'australie pour faire des fruits à ce
jour c'est pas un franc succès ça fait
ça fait deux mais jamais de fruits avec
cet angle c'est le pain de vie qui il
vaillancourt qui a importé de californie
les premiers use où il y a de cela plus
de vingt ans c'était mon plaisir
personnel regarder avec un des amis et
on s'amusait dans un taillis dans
certains restaurants montréal surtout
fait du troc
[Musique]
russell les citrons ne faut pas vivre la
fermière le revenu familial provient
d'abord des 150 acres au petit fruit
maïs sucré
tomates poivrons et course
[Musique]
les écailles et le vétérinaire à peu
près une gaffe en rigole transparent
curieusement la production de ces fruits
excentrique lui permet de vendre ses
légumes de chant ça lui cogner à la
porte de certains restaurants en faisant
puis les gens de toute la plupart des
restaurateurs de vraiment intégralement
impressionné mais je leur dis faites par
la bande
je ne ferme aussi puis je fais les
tomates des concombres des cours sur les
produits réguliers puis qu'on utilise en
cuisine
[Musique]
comme les use ou ne mûrissent pas tous
en même temps elle cueille et livres
presque tous les jours
ça prend en moyenne certains avoirs
d'avoir une bonne production donc
pendant sept ans j'ai des coûts de
chauffage extrêmement élevé avec aucun
entraîneur jean en hiver pour maintenir
les ardres dans une température
équivalente à celle du japon qu'une
seule scène tout au moins 7000 $ de
chauffage donc imaginez vous mois de
janvier quand il fait moins 40 les nuits
pour tenir une serre en plastique à 11
degrés ça coûte excessivement cher on
entend les ché
aujourd'hui elle ramasse 15 kilos
qu'elle s'est engagée à livrer en après
midi à des chefs toujours avide de
nouveautés et de produits vedettes j'ai
des clients qui attendent de prêts très
flatté longtemps qu'ils sont sur la
liste d'attenté depuis le printemps fait
donc là c'est le jour est le jour
crucial aujourd'hui pour faire attention
ça pique les use ou ont fleuri en avril
et les fruits ont mis plus de six mois à
mûrir mais tout vient à point pour celle
qui sait attendre
à preuve ce fruit étrange qui est une
autres variétés d'agrumes les mains de
bouddha ça le président à sa table à au
moins une dizaine
déjà ses fruits spectaculaires sont tous
premiers est vendu depuis l'apparition
des fleurs au mois de mars
j'ai un client l'année dernière qui m'a
pris une manne dida qui était ma plus
grosse que j'avais l'année dernière puis
m'ont dit qu'ils ont passé quatre heures
en cuisine pour tout enlever les est là
travailler pour éviter qu'elle ait le
moins de pertes possibles plus la main
porte de doigts mieux ils sont répartis
plus le fruit hohrod la valeur non plus
ont ouvert puis son large que c'est le
mec de la qualité comme celle ci elle
est encore très petit mais on voit que
vraiment beaucoup de doigts puis vont
être bien répartis une bouteille qui est
tout tout fermée sur elle même elle est
un petit peu moins de bolides
[Musique]
comme les arbres fruitiers ont grossi
avec l'aide de son père mais qui va
construire une nouvelle serre presque
deux fois plus grande décharge à côté ce
sera une séance à votre en acier on se
trouve à gorny quatre pieds c'est bon on
va me défendre si pour cela il faut
faire tourner
les tomates ont été cueillis les plans
peuvent être fauchés l'an prochain il y
aura du mali sucré à la place et on
achève de taille et les framboisiers
pour vicky la haute saison des citrons
japonais est en cours sont vraiment
prêts il y en a qui dorment encre est
peut-être encore quelques semaines avant
d'être à point mais la majorité sont
vraiment prêts une maraîchère de son
temps
chaque génération en fait apporte sont
ici sa nouveauté puis nous je pense que
ça ne touche de nouveauté risque c'est
un resto l'arbre fruitier c'est de
l'agriculture pour nous d'une façon de
nous
[Musique]